giorgia investigators this morning are
looking into the deadly shooting of a
Georgia Tech student on campus scout
Shultz was a 21 year old senior majoring
in engineering Schultz identified as
either male nor female and was president
of the school's pride alliance Georgia
Tech police responded to a call Saturday
night that led to Schultz's death
encounter was captured on cell phone
video
mark Strassmann is at the University in
Atlanta with the questions over officers
use of force mark good morning good
morning scout Schultz was shot right on
this Street around midnight on Saturday
a student killed by university police
right on campus those officers were
responding to a call about a man
carrying a gun and a knife when this
happened video you can see scout Schultz
walking toward police holding what they
believe was a pocket knife you can hear
the 21 year old student call out to them
Schultz paused before stepping toward an
officer who gave a final warning the
officer then opened fire with a single
fatal shot
Schultz died shortly after at a nearby
hospital pictures of the scene show this
small multi-purpose tool on the ground
the blade of the knife inside it was
folded Schultz had no gun in an
interview with the Atlanta
journal-constitution Schultz's mother
Lynn Schultz questioned why police
didn't use pepper spray or Tasers
she said Schulz attempted suicide two
years ago Chris Stewart the family's
lawyer told the newspaper he believes
Schultz was having a mental breakdown
and didn't know what to do
Stewart added that he doesn't believe
Schultz wanted to die in what's known as
suicide by cop but they should have had
a non-lethal option Julia gray was
friends with Schulz both belonged to the
campus LGBTQ community Scout was the one
out there marching Scout was the one
that showed an endless amount of pride
for who they were
Schultz identified as non-binary meaning
neither male nor female and was the
president of Georgia Tech's pride
Alliance no one should get to that point
where they they feel that way especially
when they don't want to hurt anyone
Scout didn't want to hurt though anyone
students have started a memorial to
Schulz er over my shoulder as you can
see state investigators are leading the
official look into this fatal shooting
we asked them whether responding
officers carried mace or a stun gun but
they had no further details for us
people are raising that question as well
mark a lot of questions in that case
thank you very much